Heart and
Mr. doblitzki
Mrs. Castrop
Mr. Philipp fürs zu Hohenlohe
Langenburg
Mrs. Dr Saskia Princess zu Hohenlohe
Mrs. Xenia zu Hohenlohe Langenburg and
Mr. Dr Andreas Nilsson
Mrs  Helmi
Mrs. parliamentary group leader Hasselmann
Mr. Ambassador Ms.
Governing Mayor of
Berlin fallen
and Mrs. habendorf
parliamentary group leader
Professor Dr russform and Ms.
a
Mr. Dr Schuster and Ms. Schuster
dr Becker
Ms. Wittwer
Ms. Professor Dr. Turkish
Ms. Saxon and Mr. Vögel
Ms. State dr Dinger and
Mr. Professor  Dr Dannemann and Ms.
Professor Dr Freitag Mr.
Bundesbank President dr Nagel
Mr. Mennekes and Ms. Mennekes
Mr. Kola and Ms. Kohler
Mr. Generalm Geblein and Ms. Gäbelein
the
authorized with Ms. privatins
party and parliamentary group chairman märz
and Ms. Merz
Ms. Hassel and Mr. Schumacher
Mr. parliamentary group chairman Dürr and Mrs.
Dürr  Member
of the Bundestag dr Zimmermann and
Mrs. Feller
Mrs. and Mr. Chef
Cirque and Lady
Mr. Friede Campino
Mr. Schmidt and Mrs. Schmidt
Mr. Dr. Klimmer and
Mr. Dr. Geisinger and Mrs. Eisfeld Mr.
Federal Minister Lindner and Mrs.
Lehfeldt
Mr. Professor Dr. Vogel and Mrs. Darwin Mrs.
Minister of State dr Lührmann and
Mr  botschafter.de
His Minister of Excellence cleverly and
Ms. family
Her Excellency the Ambassador of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain
and Northern Ireland Ms. Gallert and Hergert Ms.
King
Ms. Embassy of
the parliamentary state for
energy efficiency and green finances
Mr. defense dasch Ms.
loesch Ms.
Wilson
Ms. Langner Ms.
Slotted spoon Ms.
Heinrich
Ms. Rützel
supplement
hertelapass 10
Mr. Lutze Mr.
jusida
Hess President of
the Bundestag Dear
Mr. President of the Bundesrat, Mrs.
Tschenscher, Dear Mr. President, Mr. Habert, Mrs
Ladies and gentlemen,
dear guests and dear friends,
how things change and how one
finds the right thing in this change is what
a magion writes about in his
latest novel Lessons
Region tells the story of
Roland Beins whose life is inextricably linked to
drastic events in
contemporary history one travels
with Roland banks over the decades
always on the search for the answer to
the big question
how do you deal with those changes
that are not in your hands
and that shape your own life
dear guests welcome to the
castle is a great personal pleasure for me
and a great honor to welcome Her Majesties King
Charles and Queen Camilla Concert today
on the occasion of their first state visit
as a royal couple in Germany
and just as a region lets its
leading actor travel through the decades,
I would like to talk to you tonight about
the big questions of the German-British
Relationships talk about continuity in
change
about upheaval about new beginnings
today is 29 march
next to this day six years ago
the british government submitted its
application to leave the european
union
let me tell you quite frankly for me
personally it was a sad day and that's
how it went  many in this country quite a
few feared at the time the
Germans and Brits could lose each other over
this Brexit
but ladies and gentlemen that was
not the case
the connections between our countries are now too strong
the friendships between
people
too precious the work of reconciliation after
two world wars
our partnership has
grown over centuries the
progressive ideas of Magna Kater
and the Bill of Rights
the influence of great thinkers such as David
Hume
the music of George Frideric Handel
and the Beatles
our relationships have always been shaped by
close human bonds of
mutual inspiration
football has always been  an English
connection an English invention that
the Germans were only too happy to
copy
even if not every game between us
is a friendly match
it is good that the Germans and the British
today
at best play out realities on the soccer field
ladies and gentlemen
today our countries are
indispensable partners  together in almost every
conceivable area,
aware of our past
but full of confidence
about the future, that's what they
said when they last
visited
the German Bundestag here in Berlin, a little over
two years ago,
nothing shows this connection as
clearly as
festively  Your visit to
Germany Your Majesty on her
very first trip abroad as the new
king this
highly symbolic visit
is a truly great personal
gesture on your part
and I thank you for that
everyone in this room
thank you very much
[applause]
ladies and gentlemen on 29 March  In 2017,
the United
Kingdom left the European Union,
exactly six years later today,
we are starting a new chapter, we are
looking forward under changed conditions
and yet together, whatever lies
ahead, I know our
British-German friendship remains
important, but it remains strong  frenchel
is important
how deep our connection is
we feel especially in these times the
russian attack on the ukraine
the first war of aggression on a
neighboring country within europe since the
second world war
what has brought back memories of the worst
times on our continent
but is putin's brutal calculation  just did
n't work out he did
n't drive Europe's democracies apart
we the allies in NATO
is united kingdoms and the EU
stand closer together ever
we help those attacked in the fight
for their freedom and
independence tomorrow we will visit the
arrival center for ukrainian
refugees in tegelern  yes, as a sign of our
solidarity and also as a sign of
gratitude for the great
willingness to help and the sympathy
that the people in our countries are
showing
Germany
and the United Kingdom are today
also militarily the two biggest
supporters of Ukraine in Europe
tomorrow we will be
together with the German-
meet the British battalion in Brandenburg
and just a few days ago I visited
German and British soldiers in Estonia
who together from Estonia
secure the airspace over the alliance area of ​​NATO
together they protect the eastern flank
together they protect our
alliance area side by side
time by time or better  Said
wing by wing,
ladies and gentlemen, especially after the
terrible disaster
that the Germans brought across the continent in two world wars,
none of this can be taken for
granted
I still know how deeply moved I was in
2018 as the first German
Federal President to attend the official
British memorial event on the  To be able to take part
in London at the end of the First World War,
even to be able to speak at Abby’s Investments memorial service
and it meant a lot to me that Your
Majesty was the
first member of the
British royal family to be present
at the commemoration of the day of national mourning
in the German Bundestag in November 2020 and to have
spoken the day
after tomorrow  Friday we will
commemorate together in Hamburg the bombing of the city in 1943 80 years
after the bombing terror of German
warplanes against British cities
what a great gesture of reconciliation
from enemies of yore have become close friends
Your Majesty the work of reconciliation
the deep friendship between our
peoples  We also have you and your
family to thank for the Winzer family,
their parents, and above all their mother, Queen Elizabeth II, who
we all admire and
adore
do your
family stands for continuity
for stability,
especially in times of change
and new beginnings
my esthete you have
supported your mother on countless occasions as an ambassador for reconciliation for friendship between our nations with Germany
you also have a close personal
relationship visiting relatives
brought them
here for the first time in 1962,
they were just 13 years old at the time and
they set foot on German soil
without any official reception,
without the press, without photographers, and yet there
is an
enchanting photo of them
together with their father Prince Philip
when they arrived at the
airport in Frankfurt, being a young
journalist, who was
still an intern at the time, took the picture on
the tarmac,
it is a majestic pleasure for me to send
you this photo as a
reminder of this
special moment after 61 years, as a
sign of the long-standing bond
with our country
and since
not everyone can see the small picture, we have drawn it up here
once
[applause]
I didn't count it myself
magistrate but in the meantime you have been
to our country more than 40 times as Prince Charles
now we warmly welcome you again
her first state visit
as King Charles May 6
the day of her coronation stands for a
new beginning and of course also for
continuity
for you personally it stands for new and
even greater responsibility for the
British it stands for a
new period of their monarchy
for us and  for the relations
between our countries stands for
great continuity we build on
our centuries-long partnership on
the friendship between Germans
and Britons and honored Majesty on
your personal commitment to the
relations between our two
countries
that you with your wife Queen Camilla
even before yours  coronation travel to Germany
is as I understand it a
strong European gesture it means
a lot to me it means a lot to us Germans and
I think how much of it they were able to see for themselves this afternoon in front of the Brandenburg Gate quite well
enthusiastic Berliners
many guests from all over  Germany who
really appreciate the value of your visit
and the day of your coronation it will
be another good day for Anglo-German relations
ladies and gentlemen
we are not what happens to us
but
what we make of it that is the great
lesson  the lessons of one region,
no matter how rapid the changes are,
we are not powerless
in the face of them, if we stand together,
every new beginning succeeds and that is why
I would like to express my heartfelt
thanks again for your visit,
their Majesties,
especially as a sign of this standing together,
I am very happy  I look forward to the coming
days and the numerous opportunities
we will have to exchange ideas with one another during these three days of your
state visit
and now I would like to ask you
all
to raise glasses with me to toast the
health of Their Majesties King Charles
and Queen Camilla and to
her  Well, dear guests, to the
friendship between our two
countries, to the health and cheers
[applause] dear
Mr
to be larger company
and it's nice of you that
you came and didn't leave me alone with
a dinner for one
my wife and you are deeply touched by
how warmly we would be welcomed in Germany
just like with every one of our guides
visit this very special country
I've found that I've
actually been to Germany more than 40 times, which
of course shows how important
our relationships are to me, but
I'm also afraid of how long I've been nice
to each of these visitors, I have
memories that I like to
think back
to in Leising  we all have something to
learn from Germany's in during respect
for what got the cold the sublime
language of course
they stay language of nature
years
and by the vitality but partnership in
campus aerial
to my mother
for the touching messages of support
[music]
engineering
technology  science the warm the arts
education and Sam much
but country
promote table health developing
the Federal President
Germany and the United
Kingdom have a great interest in
the future of the other country
our relations will become even stronger
I am firmly convinced that
if we together on one
working towards a more sustainable future of prosperity and security
may the ash tree I did not
plant in her beautiful garden after noon today be
a small symbol of the growth and
blossoming of our partnership
I hope with
all my heart that my wife and I
will live long enough for us in
come back to this wonderful city and see
how our tree has grown and so that
we can continue to contribute our part to this
precious friendship between our
two countries.
Please raise a glass
[music]
to you with me, the Federal President
and Mrs. Büdenbender, and to a
friendship that  is not only cordial
but also in the truest sense of the
word sustainable for the good
[applause]